time is ticking down to the next
election down to brexit and if labor
gets its way down to the end of the
five-day week the stand out policy from
Shadow Chancellor John McDonald today a
target to get the average working week
down to 32 hours the next Labour
government will reduce the average
full-time working week to 32 hours
within the next decade in case you're
wondering it's an aspiration not a cap
the government won't prevent you working
longer in fact they think working less
is actually in business's own interests
if that sounds improbable listen to
someone who's actually trialed afford a
week like recruitment boss David stone
how much of your day your work day spent
actually working versus scrolling in
church and talking about football and
Louisville and and lunch but if you can
focus on getting the task in hand on the
productivity metrics it is perfectly
possible to do five days worth of work
in fall and that's what we've been
finding here indeed up until about a
century ago there was no such thing as
that weekend then again for business
groups the real worry is that these
rules might make firms less profitable
the idea of fewer hours at the same pay
is simply a radical increase in in wage
costs and there will be many businesses
thinking how can they afford to do that
and so it has to be done in a way that
raises productivity at the same time
but whether it's reality or a
kite-flying exercise that 32-hour pledge
is only one radical proposal from labor
alongside higher taxes rules forcing
companies to give shares to workers and
even the abolition of private schools
this is about giving people control over
their lives if you're not having to work
every hour that God sends your free time
is yours if you're owning the company
you're working for you can decide how
you work when you're dead right this is
about Union people sense of control
and a sense of power and authority over
what they're doing put it all together
and it may add up to an even more
radical manifesto than Michel foots
famous election losing 1983 won a
traditionally the main questions
economists have had about labor policy
have been fiscal how much did it cost
does it add up stuff like that but now
that the Tory party of committed to
spending billions the whole thing's been
rather turned on its head so whether
it's public schools whether it's
companies distributing shares to
employees all forcing landlords to sell
properties to their tenants there is a
deeper question does it labor respect
private property so much depends on how
this all goes down with the voters will
they be comfortable with these kind of
questions will they vote for a 32-hour a
week as the countdown to the next
election approaches we won't have to
wait long to find out at Conway Sky News